for now though first on CBS this morning
2020 presidential candidate senator Amy
Klobuchar is revealing a comprehensive
new proposal to help older Americans and
their families the Minnesota Democrats
plan assists people with Alzheimer's and
other chronic medical conditions it also
calls for strengthening Medicare and
Social Security reducing drug cost
creating personal savings accounts to
help Americans save for retirement and
slide in this plan and ensuring paid
family leave for all senator Klobuchar
is with us as part of our continuing
series the road to 2020
senator good morning thanks thanks Tony
it's great to be on thank you for being
here so politics is always personal in
part but this plan feels a little more
personal than most for you because your
father has struggled with Alzheimer's
how did that impact how you put it
together one of the things you realize
when you have someone in your family for
me my dad is 91 thankfully it didn't hit
him till later but you see them growing
more and more distance not in the heart
but in the mind and you realize
sometimes they may not even quite know
who you are and that's a hard moment
when that happens well I'm not alone
there are 14 million people right now
who have someone with Alzheimer's in
their family 14 million people have
Alzheimer's and we are not really
getting ready for this we're going to
see even more and more of it and to me
it is of course about getting a cure and
treatment that's a lot in this plan
about getting us there by 2025 and
investing but it's also about the
caregivers they may be a husband or a
wife or they may be a daughter or son
but they're heroes and they're the ones
that are there every single day
especially when the people are at home
and it's probably job helping them get
tax credits to help them do their work
yeah Alzheimer's is the most expensive
disease and disease in America costing
more than cancer and heart disease 290
billion dollars at hand that's just part
of your plan talk about what else is in
there and and how are you gonna pay for
it right well the pay for is interesting
because this plan is about seniors right
it's about keeping Medicare and Social
Security strong and also being able to
push on the drug companies because
prescription drugs common drugs like
insulin
I've gone up multiple times in just the
last few years but paying for it is
interesting if you've heard about how
the wealthiest people are able to set up
trust funds for their kids I'm not
talking about charitable trusts I'm
talking about things that people set up
for the kids that's all fine and good
but then they don't pay taxes on the
money that they make on the trust when
they go to their kids and conservative
estimates are that it would bring in at
least 200 billion dollars if you started
putting that at a normal tax rate and
whether it's the capital gains rate and
you could even change that that brings
in a lot of money that I think works
better spent on the rest of the people
in this country that need help with
retirement or need hope to take care of
a family member with Alzheimer's your
plan also calls for improving mental
health for seniors how are you actually
going to address that well you have
seniors who feel very isolated and we've
actually seen a 30 percent increase in
suicides in this country in our entire
population so when you hear these
stories at home they're not just stories
that is making sure there's people in
communities they have people to go to
that communities are aware especially
with people with Alzheimer's there's a
lot of being work being done right now
by the Alzheimer's Association and I've
seen communities in my own state where
they're training store clerks and people
who work at coffee shops when someone
comes in and they have Alzheimer's they
seem to have memory problems except it
this is how you work with them because
there's gonna be a lot of people out in
the community so there are things we can
do that don't even cost money as a
country to be able to deal with this
there's a story that's been dominating
the headlines out of Congress this week
and it's a rift between Nancy Pelosi and
and some younger Congress women in her
party in your party Nancy Pelosi scolded
them is the term I would use for some
tweets this intramural fighting do you
think Pelosi was right to call out the
tweets do you think this is gonna go
away
I got enough politics in the
presidential race but I but what I do
think is first of all Nancy Pelosi is a
very strong leader and she's got a big
party to unite and a big group of people
over there in the house but the second
thing
three members we always are going to
have differences in the Democratic Party
we are a big tent party with different
ideas and it's a lot different than the
Republicans right now who seem to have
Donald Trump say how high can you jump
to keep them happy yeah we have
differences but what unites us is much
stronger than what divides them I want
to go give me in lockstep in the same
way the Republicans are you need to be I
would say right well I think when we get
down to the election just like we did in
2018 we're going to have someone leading
the ticket I'd like it to be me I'm
someone that believes that we need to
have a presidential candidate that
doesn't just unite our party but it in
it to win in November I've won in red
districts and districts that Donald
Trump won by over 20 points and I think
you need to build that coalition and I'm
not going to make all these promises
that a bunch of other people have made
because I think you make one important
promise that you're going to govern with
integrity I think that the American
people have seen broken promises from
Donald Trump now for years and they're
ready for someone who can lead when it
is about leading and that is my message
the American people as we go forward in
this campaign I want to go back to
health care for a second because the
federal appeals court appeared
sympathetic to arguments that the
Affordable Care Act is unconstitutional
do you think we need a constitutional
amendment guaranteeing the right to
health care if we had the political
environment where we could pass
something like that that would be good
because I see health care as a right and
not a privilege but right now my focus
is on one protecting the Affordable Care
Act so that people can't get thrown off
their insurance which would be
devastating for so many people in this
country if they have any pre-existing
condition to building on it by doing
more about the pharmaceutical prices
taking them on allowing seniors to
negotiate Medicare prices bringing in
less expensive drugs from other can't
countries I lead those bills and then
the second thing the last thing I would
say is that we need to bring down the
cost of premiums and if the Trump
administration is going to keep trying
to take those things away from people
we're gonna fight back
senator Klobuchar thank you very much
for being here we appreciate it